马上就要填志愿了
是不是还在发愁
分数摸不到985
211到底去哪儿找靠谱的好大学
20天讲透志愿填的一切
今天工况一条视频
深挖普通本科里被严重低估
性价比拉满的宝藏大学
咱先看北京有三所北方工业大学
工科底子扎实
电气计算机自动化
电子信息都很能打
大部分毕业生都能留在北京工作
北京信息科技大学
机械仪器通信电子信息实力特别硬
去华为
小米
京东
百度这些大厂实习就业都很方便
首都经济贸易大学
金融会计统计是王牌
毕业能去北京的银行
券商或者国企财务部门
想在北京学财经
首经贸
绝对性价比拉满天津
推荐两所天津财经大学
老牌财经院校
校友资源遍布天津的财政税务银行系统
在华北地区认可度很高
中国民航大学
民航局直属
被被誉为民航业的黄埔军校
飞行技术这类民航类专业都很强势
行业认可度没得说
河北也有两所燕山大学
机械四小龙之一
发源于哈工大重型机械系第五轮学科评估
机械师A检是学校的招牌
行业认可度比一些985都要高
石家庄铁道大学
原铁道部直属轨道交通是王牌专业
毕业能去各地的铁路局工作
想进铁路系统拿铁饭碗
石铁大绝对是个好选择
山西我推荐两所宝藏大学
第一所中北大学兵工七子之一
遗弃在第五轮学科评估问拿到了
但要爆破装甲车辆
这些专业非常硬核
军工背景深厚
第二所太原科技大学
原机械部直属机械材料自动化设计都很扎实
重型机械领域认可度提高
再来看辽宁东北财经大学
财政部教育部共建
财经领域实力很硬核第五轮学科评估
应用经济学
中山管理都是A统计学
A检保研率有15%
想在东北学经管的东财绝对值得
辽宁工程技术大学原煤炭部之术
在煤炭电力领域的底蕴很深
电气能动专业的毕业生
很多都能进东北的电力系统
吉林推荐两所长春理工大学
兵工七子之一光学
在第五轮学科评估拿到了A人称光学英才摇篮
毕业生技能进中国兵器
中航科技
央国企也能去海康威视京东方这些企业
另一所东北电力大学
原电力部直属高校
进国家电网人数全国第三
东北电网系统的绝对主力
还有能动
新能源
核工程专业也能轻松进入电力系统共和国长子
黑龙江也有两所
哈尔滨理工大学
电气是招牌
电缆方向
全国顶尖
近黑龙江电网人数全国第一
机械仪器自动化
计算机
这些专业实力也都很顶
黑龙江大学俄语是王牌专业
哲学法学马理论也很有底蕴
不过学校整体偏文
工科相对弱一些
接下来看看华东地区
这里宝藏大学非常多
先来看上海
上海理工大学
机械生物学
工程光电专业都很强势
而且上海都有对应产业
毕业生在上海的就业质量非常好
华东政法大学五院四系之一
法学第五轮学科评估达到知识产权
国际法
这些方向都很强
毕业主要去上海各大律所企业
法务或者公检法系统
上海电力大学
原电力部直属电力系统认可度极高
仅上海电网人数全国第一
很多毕业生能够去到国网南网
五大六小发电集团
上海电气这些央国企
江苏推荐四所镇江的江苏大学
农业部共建农业工程是王牌
在第五轮学科评估里面拿到食品A减
机械材料自动化实力也很扎实
在长三角实习就业都没问题
扬州大学学科门类超全
硕博点数量在全国同类院校里面排第二
兽医学全国顶尖临床汉源农学
水利水电这些专业也可
南京工业大学原化工部直属
化工是绝对王牌
第五轮学科评估拿到了A
材料安全专业也很强势
在精细化工
新材料安全领域的认可度堪比985
南京工程学院有原电力部背景
电力系统认可度极高
进江苏电网人数全国第一
浙江有四所
第一所
浙江工业大学
省内仅次于浙江大学
化工是王牌中的王牌
第五轮学科评估拿了A机械自动化
计算机
这些工科也很强势
而且保研去浙大的特别多
第二所杭州电子科技大学四电自由之一
第五轮学科评估
计算机是A减
电子通信自动化实力也很顶
在本d i it圈认可度极高
第三所浙江理工大学纺织工程师王牌
第五轮学科评估A加机械材料
计算机
这些工科也都不弱
在长三角实习就业都很能
第四所浙江工商大学统计学
第五轮学科评估拿了A还有会计
金融
电子商务也都是王牌
长三角财经商贸领域
校资源非常丰富
安徽推荐一所安徽理工大学
是原煤炭部直属爆破专业
全国顶尖毕业能够去军工
矿业安全类的国企或者奇瑞海螺这些本地企业
福建我推荐两所福建师范大学
师范类专业是绝对的王牌
第五轮学科评估里面有三个A类专业
省内教育系统认可度很高
集美大学学校最大特点是靠海吃海
航海技术
轮机工程
水产养殖
全国都能打
财经师范类专业在省内也有认可度
江西有两所
第一所江西财经大学
第五轮学科评估拿到A减
会计金融财政也很强势
校友资源遍布江西和珠三角
第二所南昌航空大学
航空航天专业省内独一档
有中航工业
洪都航空定点招聘毕业生
进航空航天央国企的比例很高
再来看山东第一所青岛大学临床纺织识王牌
计算机自动化材料
这工科也还不错
可以进本地医院或者海尔海信格尔街企业
第二所山东科技大学
自动化计算机安全专业实习扎实
和华为海尔潍柴这企业有联合培养
实习资源丰富
每年进山东电网的人数也很多
然后我们来看看华中和华南地区
首先河南第一所洛阳的河南科技大学
前身是洛阳工学院
机械专业是王牌轴承方向
全国顶尖
全国大部分的轴承企业都有河科大毕业生
第二所焦作
河南理工大学
安全采矿测绘专业底蕴深厚
自动化电气计算机也都不弱
仅河南电网人数全国第二
省内制造业认可度很高
湖北也有两所
武汉科技大学
材料是绝对的王牌
耐火材料方向全国第一
机械自动化计算机也都不弱
宜昌的三峡大学
原电力部直属水利水电电气专业全国顶尖
25年进国家电网人数全国第二
水电力央国企内部认可度极高
湖南推荐两所
第一所长沙理工大学
有原电力部
交通部的底子
电气交通两大王牌
特别能打
是湖南电网校招第一站
录取人数全省第一
第二所衡阳的南华大学
临床医学是王牌
毕业生进核电系统的比例很高
临床护理在省内也有认可度
广东有四所学校值得推荐
深圳大学算是双非一
但学科实力和分数线超过不少的211
计算机通信
人工智能光学都很能打
学校有钱又背靠深圳实习和就业资源
完全没话说
广东工业大学
机械电气自动化
计算机电子信息
这些工科都很强势
珠三角认可度极高
毕业生能够去到美的
格力
广汽这些本地制造企业
广州大学广州市的亲儿子
师范专业的省内认可度很高
计算机通信仪器
这新工科实力也不错
适合想在珠三角发展的孩子
深圳技术大学材料光学电子专业实力雄厚
课程和产业需求精准对接
和华为腾讯
比亚迪都有深度合作
很多人大二大三就被这些企业抢走了
最后我们来看一下西部的省份
重庆
我推荐两所
重庆邮电大学
四电自由之一
通信计算机电子
这新工科实力非常强
通信行业认可度极高
毕业生能够进腾讯阿里字节或者三大运营商
西南政法大学五院四系之一
法学第五轮学科评估拿到了A校友
遍布全国
公检法系统
在西南和华南地区的就业认可度非常高
四川也推荐两所绵阳的西南科技大学
军工背景深厚
材料机械师王牌
和不少军工单位深度合作
不少毕业生能够进西南地区的国防科工系统
广汉的中国民用航空飞行学院
民航局直属
被誉为民航飞行员摇篮
飞行技术专业是绝对的招牌
国内民航大多的飞行员都是从这儿毕业的
云南呢有一所昆明理工大学
下一轮双一流的热门种子选手
冶金材料兽王牌有色冶金行业认可度极高
机械电气计算机
这些也都不弱
近云南电网人数全国第一
陕西我推荐两所西安理工大学
人称陕西小清华
工科实力非常硬
电气自动化
通信控制仪器
这些工科都很强势
都有博士点进
陕西电网人数全国第一
西北政法大学五院四系之一
在西北地区教育资源非常丰富
甘肃有两所兰州交通大学
原铁道部直属西北地区铁路人才的摇篮
轨道交通车辆电气专业底蕴深厚
很多遍学生能够进兰州电网
兰州铁路局
中车兰州这些央国企
兰州理工大学
原机械部直属工科
底子很厚
机械材料能动专业实力很强劲
进甘肃电网人数全国第一
如果这期视频对你有帮助
欢迎点赞收藏加关注
我是框框
让我们下期视频再见